All right. Welcome to the DDPS seminar, everyone. Before we introduce our invited speaker, let's go over some rules as usual. First of all, please mute yourself during the talk. If you have immediate questions, you're welcome to unmute and ask or otherwise, please use the chat room to post your questions, so that we can address them in the q&a session at the end. Second, today's seminar is open to external audience, so no classified discussion is allowed. Finally, the talk will be recorded and uploaded to our YouTube channel. Now, let me introduce our speaker. It is an honor to host Eduardo Gildin, who is currently a professor of petroleum engineering at the Texas A&M University, and is the holder of the LF Peters and forensics professorship in petroleum engineering. He received his PhD from potestas of the University of Texas at Austin in aerospace engineering and has held postdoctoral positions with Rice University and UT Austin. His research has been supported by grants from NSF, DOD, DOD, NSA and industry, with main topics in physics based and data driven, reduced order modeling, for reservoir simulation, and optimization, and truly modeling control and automation. He was inducted into the SPE distinguished membership in 2021. Today, he will talk about guided deep learning manifold linearization of porous media flow equations for digital twin operations. Please enjoy the wonderful talk. Now without further ado, let me hand it to not agree with him by asking a random question. So where is the place that you like the most in Brazil? I'll say my, my home country, my home city, San Paolo. Like for flat patients and sunlight? Well, I mean, as people say, in Brazil, you gotta go to Rio de Janeiro during the day, and some Paulo during the night. So that's good. So the stage is now rose. Okay, thanks so much. Thank you, thank you tonic for the nice introduction. Thank everyone for joining my, my seminar. It's, it's a pleasure and honor to be here. And I know I've been watching many of those, the DDPS seminars myself, and I really liked it. And you guys are doing really great on that spectrum. So let me talk a little bit about what I've been doing in the last few years. My researcher and mod reduction has been going on for many, many years now. But we are moving a little bit on the, you know, trying to put things on a digital twin perspective. And I'm gonna show to you a couple of things that we are doing, I will start out with a the idea of digital twin, at least from a drilling prospective drilling engineering perspective, and we're going to move on to reservoir engineering. So that we set the stage for what I mean by digital twins operation. This is a joint work, at least under the visualizations and the digital twin framework with a Gentile from the visualization department and the know the machine learning scientific machine learning with Elizabeth Raghunatha, from Electrical Engineering here at a&m and many other my students, you know, I know many of the the work that I'm going to principally be presenting is from Emilio, who is now at Petrobras in Brazil, Marcela, who is now at Exxon, Mobil. Narendra, there is a McKinsey and Enrique, there's a postdoc here and Levi, that's a postdoc, as well with a Docker Braga, Neto and other students are being been working on on that. Okay, so, I'm not going to spend too much time on the why we're doing this, I think this seminar series, at least from what we are watching here, that explains really well why model reduction and other things are important. But for my perspective, we are going to a new wave of, you know, implementations of porous media flow. And and, you know, given that, you know, there is CCUS, hydrogen storage, geothermal, and even hydrocarbon production, right, you know, the net zero emissions paradigm. It's important, but we all know that, you know, in some ways, petroleum engineers on the subsurface and that's a quote that I get from a faculty here at a&m, who is very much into a subsurface as well. So, that's why we still keep into doing what, what I'm doing on on the subsurface flows, okay, but there is a commonality between all these issues here on the can be CCUS, geothermal hydrocarbon or hydrogen storage. As you may know, they all have a, you know, a certainty related to everything. Not only technical, political, economical, but everything that we do in that Rearm, right. And they are all part of a family of large scale simulation problems, right, we are using somehow a subsurface flow simulation for prediction. And they are computationally expensive. And not only that, it's not about only simulating, but it's about getting an answer, and an answer meaning a fast and robust way to obtain an optimized answer whatever optimize mean, I'm not going to the optimization process itself here in my talk. But no optimization can mean minimize risks can be increased storage for co2, for instance, production and anything that you want. But the problem is that we are calling this simulator many, many times you need the know, a way to know to get a fast answer out of that. Okay, so that's the idea here. And not only that, one interesting article that was posted in JpT. was, you know, a couple of years ago, and you can say that it's a little it's a little bit old. Yeah, already. But now they talk a little bit about, you know, the deal, one way to solve the issues, using, you know, moving forward with this transition, it is that we're going to have to digitize a lot more the operations of things that we do nowadays, right. And that's why I moved on to elaborate on the digital twin concept, and energy, which is not new. Right? If you look at, you know, there was a paper published in 2018 that actually talk about the last 10 years now, back then the last 10 years of a digital twin in energy. Right, and, you know, back then, we're mostly on replication of platforms and the operation itself. Annotated. Okay. So something popped up here from annotation, I don't know what what is that? But anyway. So. So even for turbines and everything, so the digital twin concept is not new. Right. So let me show what are we actually doing on that reel? Okay. The problem that happens, and the last 510 years is that, you know, what I joined a&m 13 years ago, I used to see it on many of the industry board meetings. And faculty used to complain a lot that the companies wouldn't give data, right? We don't have data, we don't have data. Now we have a new problem, right, which is that the companies actually everybody wants to give data. And we don't know what to do with that data. So the old rhetoric that we don't have enough data may not apply anymore. And you can see that, you know, in drilling operations, we are getting no information on the beat. And this is a Halliburton Cerebro drill bit that you can get, you know, accelerometers and other measurements directly on the beat with 1000 hertz of frequency. Right. So it's a lots of data, we have a de distribute acoustic and distribute temperature sensing that you have gigabytes of data, terabytes of data being shipped to the along the well, right. And we don't know what to do with this, this data, right. So somehow, we need a some form of data reduction, model reduction and a combination of those things to actually implement things on the digital twin framework. Let me let me just give you a glimpse of one thing that we are doing on the drilling side, then we're going to move on to the reservoir side. And that's a joint work with a Gentile, the one that I mentioned before, and that where we tried to do a digital twin for drilling optimization problems. Okay. Not going to go into details on the drilling itself. But basically, we have a drilling machine right here. And we still have, you know, the problem is very complicated, prohibitively expensive to simulate everything. So while we are focusing, we're focusing on the drill bit DBH a simulation here. Okay, so just think about that we are right at this tip of this drill bit, right. And of course, we have data from information from logs information from how the structure of the geological media works, and we're going to try to employ a digital twin to recreate environment and the platform for Good morning. Okay, so that's, and as I mentioned, we're going to just focus on the BHA, right, the PHA. So we are modeling this in the this BHA framework. So let me show you a quick video, if it is, pops up, hopefully will have our digital twin implementation for drilling optimization. And that's basically a real time drilling operation. In getting real time data from a system, we have here, a miniaturized drilling machine. So that's where we get real time data. Right. But anyway, so I did the focus here is not drilling, per se. So let me just close this and move on, hopefully. Let me just close this and move on to this one. And basically, what we implemented here is a reinforcement learning for, you know, trajectory, steering on on this drilling, drilling machine. Okay, so there's a paper coming up. But the nice thing about that we can optimize and everything. But as I said, the problem is not drilling per se. And the thing is that drilling is this a small part of these digital twin operations that we want to do, right, I'm going to for the interest of time, I'm going to come back to this in the end, if I have time, I'm gonna show the trajectories late later in the end. But the idea is that in real time operations, we want to put together not only the drilling itself, right, we want to put together a reservoir characterization model, we want to put together first reservoir simulation model. And we want to have a certainty associated with that as well. Right? So it says it's a much more complicated problem just does go into a game like and if you look at what we've done, we will use a game ancient framework, right? To develop our, our digital twin for drilling, but for reservoir, that's a different story, right? There's a little bit more complication going from a simulation of these this entire loop, right. Okay. So, but in my perspective, right, we already have something or a digital a reservoir simulator is a digital twin by nature, right? If you look at what we are doing in the digital twin, right, we are replicating the effect of a certain things, right, with real time data. And, and the problem with a reservoir simulation to become a digital twin is exactly that digital twin requires real time data integration into these built environment. And if you look at this problem here, this is a Unison benchmark from a Brazilian University Unicamp. One can take a look at, but if you look at just to this small problem here, right, we have a bout, you know, a 1 billion of states, right? What I mean pressures and saturations and concentrations, and so on and so forth. Right? With, you know, if you're going to optimize with about 1500 variables to optimize, so we need to do something else with that, that simulation to became to be able to do a digital twin framework. And there's enablers that does that, it is exactly model reduction and data driven modeling, at least in my perspective, right. So, so, let me let me let let me, let me go to that direction. Now. Let me show what we're doing to do this model reduction or reservoir simulation perspective. And I, I know, suffice to say that, you know, you know, reservoir simulation is a is a hard thing to do. And as I mentioned, you're looking at a couple partial differential equations, lots of states variables, lots of control variables, and so forth. Okay. Let me just, you know, this slide here serves for you to know, what are the states that we're looking at pressures and saturations for this reservoir, okay. But as far as the output goes, right, one, look at all your rates or water rates that you can do no co2 rates, and so forth. And usually, this is handled by what's called peace of mind equation here. It's a semi empirical equation right here. And that's one part of the issue that we're going to try to solve later on in my slide, it is how we handle actually this output. Okay, this output with the most of the model reduction techniques that are out there, they only look at state, right, they never looked at the output by itself. And if you're going to couple days with a an optimizer, output is the most important thing that one has to look at. Okay, so just keep that in perspective. So what is the model reduction problem? model reduction problem is actually trying to determine Have a replica of that, you know, fine scale model that one can have outputs, you know, almost equal, right outputs almost equal, right? And the machinery they go through to do that, it depends upon if you want to do physics based if you want to do data driven, and so forth. Okay. So what is the approach that we have taken in the past? Okay, the approach is there is the classical approach of projection based model reduction. And that's basically if you have a, an equation like this can be a reservoir simulation, it can be the reservoir equation, right? We assumed that we can project, right, these states large scale system states into a much smaller subspace right here, we're using this V, which we'll call projection, right, and we can project this that, you know, the classical approach, and we can get a reducer model out of that. Okay. And that's the, you know, many, many people have have done that we have several papers on that. But there are issues with that implementation, it is that, you know, 111 thing, one look at this nonlinear function. And, of course, being a nonlinear function, one can, you know, doesn't have a, when you project this, you still have to go back to the full scale system to actually solve the system. And this somewhat being fixed with a discrete input interpolation or some kind of interpolation in that knowing a space. Right. But the problem as well, it is that there is a separate issue, there is no output information used on this on this translation here. Okay. So that's one thing that we're going to try to fix. Another, you know, projection based model reduction is really nice, you can get really good, you know, reduction. And, you know, I haven't tried yet Libran myself, and I know that you guys have a good understanding of that. But projection based model reduction, per se, it is not a robust way of solving the problem. Why? Because here's, you know, you have a, let's say, a reservoir, it's a cartoon, like, with a wells here, there's X dots, what happens if you move a well, from a place to another place, your reducer model completely breaks down? Okay, there's no way to know, at least in the classical approach, there is no way to handle that the dynamical system is completely different. Okay. Of course, I mean, as well, if you drill a new well, or if you open and close these wells, things breaks down. And the problem is exactly how to handle these boundary conditions, right? Because the boundary if you if you have an offline training process, right, and the classical approach, you know, if you do SVD, right, and the online approach, the boundary conditions are completely different, right? So we somehow have to some have a form of adaptivity to do that. And we work a little bit on on that, the paper many, many years ago with Jana Fannia, from the math department, that somehow, you know, adaptively, we, you know, try to solve, you know, reconstruct that basis, but it's still, you need a fast solver to reconstruct the basis and back then use a multiscale type of solver. And, you know, it's nice, but, you know, if you're gonna go and apply this, for much larger problems, that may not be the way to go. Okay, so, here's an example of a a classical physics based model reduction applied to a hydraulic fracturing process with a cup of flow and geomechanics. Right. If you only look at you know, here we have a well a two wells actually parallel wells with a and we tested out from eight to 24 fractures here the 824 is how many fractures you have in here, and it takes a Class A take no snapshots of precious saturations and this and the displacement, sorry, the measurements of the displacements, and you'll go through this physics space and you get a good speed up here. And you can see that as more fractured as you get more speed up that you get exactly because there is a there's overhead associated with the process. So the more accurate you get, of course, there will be a higher speed up on the process. As I mentioned, we if we do some changes on this, things will break down and that's what we want I always in my paper, they say when he works, it works really well. Right? And it's still not too robust yet for for lots of tweaking and here and there, okay. All right. So, what are the existing solutions that we are looking at and why we are going through? Okay? So many of these things have already been done in our been published, right? Pod daima TBWA, our dynamic mode decomposition, neural nets, etc, that we're going to talk to explore a little bit more and lifting Berlina realizations, okay? Some of them, they have a good handling some of them they have gaps, right? So what I'm going to show to you in the next, maybe 20 minutes or so, is a combination of these methodologies. Okay, in particular, you're going to show Ecco, I'm going to show something in binarization. That's basically the title of the, the, the talk today. So if you go back to the reservoir equation, right, on the PDE equation, you can now write up a discretize form, right? And it discretize forms can be written up on this framework here that I call a classical system framework, right, where ABCD can be our matrices. And they are not necessarily constant matrices, they are a function of the time, right? And that's part of the nonlinear problem associated with this, these equations. But the question is, if working write this up these equations by hand, you solve the problem, right? It's really hard to do that, especially because you have a very nonlinear problems that you don't know how to you get to go and get all these Jacoby, Ian's and so forth, inside the system. So build it up this matrix is ABCD. It is important. And if you can do that, without accessing the simulator code, it will be really nice odd hypotheses here it is that one going to estimate those matrices birth based upon only a dynamic evolution of the state. And it turns out that it's possible, it's possible if you look at what's called embedded to control, okay, and embedded to control it is as follows. If you have a system, and you have snapshots for your simulation, let's call this x, you can go through an encoder decoder framework. And I'm going to show what I mean by this transitions in a minute, right. And you can get out of this A and B information of that today. So it's a paper a couple of years ago that use that for reservoir simulation. And we thought, well, that's really nice. But we have if we don't have information about the output, so what we do with that output, might want to can reconstruct the output by going through a piece of an equation, that's great. But if you have a optimizing things that are closing and open wells, that may not work too well. So what we've done, we took that to one next level, and we developed a D to C O and observe, observe here. Okay, we're in the following way, we now are creating not only a, b, and then in that in that equation here, but we're creating C and D, as well, as you go and train does not does not work. So going through these networks. Just go a little bit into details. I mean, the network itself can it's in the paper, okay. But one can create a network with transitions input and output, state and output, whereby one look at, you know, a series of dense layers, batch normalization value, and the output A, B, C, and D. That's really nice. We tested you know, a small problem here with a training with the this particular we have several wells, in particular, you know, input to the system, right? And you get a good, really nice output information here. I can go into details later on, if you if you want me to go through this, how we actually implemented this. But as far as the training goes, if you have a good implementation of an GPUs, in our case, this is a small system it took us 38 minutes right now for some if you go to bigger bigger problems than for training purposes, that might be much larger timing for for training. But the nice thing is that if you compare the high fidelity simulation here on the left with this Ecco right at At least visually speaking, you can say there is a really good matching. Right. But as far as a matching the well rates, that's even better, right? You can say that, you know, the high fidelity simulation here is the black one. And the, the green is the TCO. And if you look at the reconstruction, that's called Proposition one here, the reconstruction are for using abysmal equation. It's a little bit far off. So we think that our methodology, it's a little bit better than just reconstructing the, the, the piece of an equation, right, and especially when you open and close wells. And then we handle we also run some statistics that one can look at this on the paper as well. And ATCL always get a little bit better. In running this many, many times, I always get a better, you know, error, as compared to the just reconstructing by abysmal equation. We took this a little bit farther and say, Well, can we do a 3d model? Can we do a bigger model? And the answer is yes. But if you look at our 3d models, that usually they have a no active grid blocks, write D to C, or D to co cannot handle that in some ways, because you need a some chi square architecture or a rectangular architecture, right. But we are able to handle this with a partial convolution layers, right? They can explain later on if it needs to. But here is the solution for this ag model. With a with our E TCO that we have a paper in preparation that was going to show all the demonstration here and the timing. So hopefully, that will be published soon as well. So that's great. I spent maybe half an hour or so to talk a little bit about that. But let me move on to the issues that we encounter as doing it to co write and, and one of the issues. Was that exactly on the nonlinearities. Right. And as I said, many times you get, you know, things to work, when times you get things not to work, especially if you go from the classical model reduction to a little bit on this, etc. Oh, and etc. Oh, by the way, it's a it's if you look at the word implementation, exactly trajectory piecewise implementation with a proper orthogonal decomposition embedded into it. So but the the proper orthogonal decomposition get on using this encoder decoder framework, right. So there is still some issues with nonlinearities. And one way that we sought to solve the problem was to look back what we've done. And now maybe six, seven years ago, on writing up the nonlinear equations into what's called a bi linear form. Okay, back then, we wrote this by linear form. What I mean by that if you have a full order system here, the same way that we had before, we can write this up into this biding their form right here, this Medina form, which can get us a little bit better handling on the nonlinearities. The thing is that in when we published the paper, we wrote that binarization by hand, okay, and as you're gonna see, this nonlinear is a linearization, or does binarization depend upon augmenting the states? Right? So if you have states x to be order of n, right, when we go to these states, here, on the Ballina form, you're actually almost doubling the number of states, right? And back then, if you look at the paper, right, we are not able to solve much larger problems. We had a very tight example was very nice, theoretically what we wrote, but we hit at that time a wall say, well, we cannot proceed further. What happens in the last five, six years was the development of this notion of the Koopman operator, right? I did the deep neural net basic mobile operator, and I'm going to show you the next slide, what a basically Koopman operator, and the Cooper operator allows you to go to a node does binarization in a much cheaper, cheaper way. Okay. And that basically what we are proposing we're proposing to go from this loneliness system to a Koopman operator, writing up as a body in a form and then operating on this body in a form and creating projectors to do that. This model reduction step, okay. Of course, this is not so easy, right? Otherwise, we'll be really happy Right. And I'm going to show in the next slides what what issues we encounter doing that and how we actually fixed some of the issues. Okay, so but anyway, so the idea is actually writing up a Koopman operator to binarize the system, and then the projection on the fly using this projection matrices fi and cy. Alright, so Koopman operator, a couple of theory is not new. It's something that, you know, was developing the TARDIS and basically, it is trying to write up this new set of coordinate systems, so that you can kind of somehow linearized the system, right, so you write this up into a higher dimension, state space, that you can see a linearization out of that. So here an original manifold. And thanks to the papers here by Nathan and cuts in Brunton, they'll move down from the the theory, only the theory to actually something more, that's really efficient computation, okay. So, we can go from the original manifold to a flat manifold using this Koopman theory. And the classical example here, not spend too much time is actually looking at this od e, if you have this od E, which is nonlinear, if you can find this operator, sigh here, whatever the operator is, right, and introduce this operator into your dynamical system. Okay, one can look at the new equation here in the bottom, right, as a linear operator. Okay, it's a linear operator. So that's basically the idea, right? But finding this function, finding this function, it is the hard thing. And that's what, you know, prevented us from moving on from this paper to do something else with that, right? We didn't know how to do it, right. So, so, how does the How does it work? Okay. So, imagine that you have a full simulation here, right? And you run the simulator using your equations, whatever, whatever you have, and then you save up the states Okay, say about the snapshots of the states. So, while one does for determined the Koopman operator, it is as follows. You take these snapshots, you run these snapshots through a series of networks here, deep learning networks, okay. And not only that, you have a encoding process here, that you go from a high order space to low order space kind of going doing a projection, right, if you look at these encoding, is basically doing a projection. Okay, so you you train this network, using the states such that you find the Koopman operator, but at the same time, you find the projection matrices, sigh and fees here that we were going to use to project the system. Okay, of course, you can look at this is just a garlic garlic Galerkin process, you can do Petrov, Galerkin, that's the same type of experimentation, right, but one goes to this network and train this network and find this V and find these projection matrices that you have now, a set of coordinates in the latent space and the A matrix is actually read read up directly from this network. Okay. So let let me so that's basically the the Koopman operator process. So let me show we implemented this, we start up with a very simplistic case with a bottle levered, right, which highly nonlinear and nonlinear in some sense, and has issues. Especially you're going to try to apply this to the physics inform neural net framework. Right. So here's our equation. If, as I mentioned, if there's some work on trying to do this in the physics inform neural net framework, right. And of course, I mean, the classical approach for handling a book elaborate is to add up this artificial viscosity for stability purposes right. So if you add up this stability parameter for you can guarantee stability of these these book elaborate right this additional office stability has been solved by having another Now this slide is a A flux and chill IP that developed some how to actually introduce this artificial viscosity, right using a pin. But here, we try to solve using what we call a, we turn these into learn a learnable parameter. So I'm not going to dwell too much, that's not the point here. The point is that, you know, the bottle average has stability issues, one can fix using a learnable, parameter learnable viscosity. Alright, as you can see here, okay, we can see those, you know, by using adaptive learning learnable viscosity, we can actually stabilize the system. But the using the use of Koopman operator can also stabilize the system. Okay, so here's the, here's the, the solution. Okay? So if you say, you know, varying boundary conditions, using this framework for the Kuiper operator, right? What can actually stabilize the solution of this book leverage? Okay, so that gave us a little bit of hope, on how to explore this for much for single phase two phase and multi phase flow, right. And that's the solution here. And by the way, so the, if you look at just the bottle average, I know they're comparing, you know, this may not be a fair comparison, given that our proxy was done in a different framework in the different platform, but just look at, if you have a 1000s of simulations of a book, elaborate, may take 1.2 hours, in our case, using these Kanban process, it takes 2.3 seconds, just to keep these into perspective. Okay, so now, going a little bit more for two phase flow, right, we apply this for going for two phase flows here with two producers and one injector. And let me show a little bit what the the issues were developing this for a much larger problem. Okay, as you're gonna see, there are actually not only five oh, this is part of the training process. And I think I forgot to mention, right, how they actually train this, right? You trained by based upon a introducing loss functions into the process, right, to guarantee some, some matching of the states and outputs and other things, okay. As you're gonna see, the process is not yet efficient in the following way, you still have lots of loss functions that we have to deal with. Right? And not only five as written up here, but you have actually, the whole framework, is that actually eight loss functions, and we don't know what to do with them, you know, to be honest, right? How do you combine them up into a much, much less a number of loss functions? But the idea here is, is that on the training process, right? Wanting to reduce the loss function for the auto encoder, right that we want to match up the state. We also want to match up the the coupon state and Latin space, right? And we want to match up the prediction in X and other things as well. Okay, so those are the last functions that one has to guarantee to, to make the student to work. Okay. When we showed that we actually, we hit a wall. I mean, there was a Marcelo de la kortesis, here at a&m A year and a half ago, we hit the wall. Well, we cannot do it. Why? Because, again, coming back to the problem of having controls and output, right, if you write this up the for the coupon for function for the reservoir simulation equation, there is always a term here, right. And it's a simplistic, you know, differentiation here, but it is a term that is a nonlinear in control that we know how we don't know how to handle that. Okay, so we started for nonlinear system, we could potentially discover the Koopman operator, but there's always going to be a nonlinear function here that cannot be discoverable. Okay. So at that time, we hit the wall, like maybe a year and a half, two years ago, and all of a sudden, Marcela was very diligent, diligent, and found a solution. Okay. And the solution was the following. There was a paper here 2021 that talks about the following. If you have a system, a nonlinear system, that is controller fine. Why don't we control a fine if you can pull out the control you in this particular form. Okay? The system can be by linearized. Okay, that's the paper. That's basically what the paper tells, if you have a system that is control control a fine, right? The system can be by linearized. And how do you by linearize, you apply these to the control. I mean, there is a process here in place. But basically what you find, instead of finding just a matrix, you find n and B matrix in this way, a n and b matrix A here. So, that's exactly what we did. We took that and we bind in our eyes, based upon the guarantee that one can do that, given the fact that reservoir equations are in this controller fun way. Okay, so here's the solution. Applying this to a controller find perspective and Bollinger eyes, the with the controls, here's the solution. Using to know, again, you know, at least from you know, inspection, you can see that the proxy model can handle really well, the saturation France and everything, especially for very well rates. Okay, very well rates. But that's not necessarily the the whole story, because you might end up with a, a matrix, that it may not be necessarily stable. Okay. And that's what I meant that there are lots of Allah's functions that we added up to make this a little bit more robust. Okay. And one way that we handle this A matrix not to be stable, we basically said, instead of let's, let's say the A matrix is small matrix, right? It's, it comes into Latin, it's formed a Latin space, so it's a small matrix. So we can afford to calculate the Eigen values. And what we do, if we have Eigen values that are outside of the unit circle, right, we clicked them off, we clip them off. And luckily, that didn't happen too often. But there was a particular loss function that we introduced to clip that, or to to guarantee that you'd have a stable solution for the A matrix. Okay, again, remember what I mentioned, we have too many loss functions that we we don't know yet how to combine them together. Okay. But anyway, so, if the system are stable, then they can see that matching the results and the well locations are really good. Okay, with errors, you know, point 4% point 4% for water saturation and pressures. So we really gave us hope to do that. Okay. Now, the second issue that we encounter, right, is as follows. That's great. We can do that. And I'm, I'm about to stop here in maybe a couple more minutes. That's great, we can find this a n and B's, but that depends upon how actually initialize the system, okay. So, you given a seed for that training stochastic process depends upon the how we actually train you may get not so good results, okay. So, we Marcella had a second contribution here was as follows why don't we use what we know already, which is a DMD right to initialize with a very few snapshots, we initialize a and b given already the you know, proper snapshots of the system, okay. So given proper snapshots of the system, okay. We can initialize the a n and b, okay, using this idea by linear mode decomposition, okay. So the if you look at the paper, one can look at Berlina realizations, right? And one can, no reason, create in a very efficient way, a very initial value for A and B. Okay, I'm not going to go into details on DMD, Berlina DMD but one can do that. And so what we call a stepwise training process, we we train the encoder, then we create, we use a few snapshots of the states, we initialize a and b and then we with that initial states A and B, we train all together for the final result. Okay. And as a comparison here, again, one simulation 45 seconds for that model. And if you have a 220 there was the dataset that we had. It took us four hours in the MRS See, but as opposed to 40 seconds in our, our framework with really good, stable results and robust results. Okay, so some remarks here, and then I'll close down things that are, you know, entirely build on I states snapshots and, you know, we add up output information. And we are able to reconstruct the surrogate, doing, you know, this idea of Biden or recession. Okay, one thing that we're working on at the moment, it is as follows. We can, you know, if you look at the control theory, right, the balanced rotation, it is actually a better model reduction, working for at least for linear system, right? Balanced vacation, it is the way to go for if you have input and output, that's what our main objective, so what we are working on, is actually translating this, this framework into this bio balanced application framework. Okay. And I'm gonna skip some of this. Okay. And the balanced location framework is actually a something that looks at controllability and observability, right? It's really good for linear systems, and basically translates to find this controllability functions, peace and observability functions cues, okay, that identify states that are easy to control, and observer observation that are difficult to to measure. Okay, so if you put this into perspective, right, they're called grammarians, and we, if you look at the equations, one look at how to calculate those graduates, right. But in the end, it turns out that, for our case, for taking that framework for doing balanced rotation, it's just a matter of adding warmth or loss function. Okay, one more last function, which is minimizing the trace of these two equations here. Okay. And we have a paper coming up that talks about that, right. But basically, that's the solution here using balanced truncation. Okay. And one can say that you get, you know, really good results with balanced truncation. Anyway, so that input output perspective that can match really well input and output. Okay. So let me just conclude here, we propose in our summation for a nonlinear system to more amenable form he to co piecewise linearization. But in our form, as I said, we have used several loss functions too many to be honest, right. And hopefully, that we will be able to fix this in an in the near future. But the nice thing is that we have the addition of the output information, which may be really important for some, some implementation in some applications. Okay. As we speak, in our Marsella, had graduated, so I have another student now, taking these up one notch, and doing this for CCS. So interesting how to implementation for carbon capture. So hopefully, we're going to do that, and have another student looking at possibilities of using transfer learning one, boundary condition changes, okay, exactly. When you when you open and close wells when you move well, locations, how we actually, if you're gonna do optimization for, or, well, location optimizations, how actually one can handle these into our framework. And finally, as I mentioned, I haven't tested Libra myself. And I'm eager to get my hands dirty, and get maybe some of these implementation into Libra. So with that, I'm gonna finish here. I acknowledge some of my collaborators, as I mentioned in the beginning, and some of the funding here. And I'm open for questions and answers and anything that you want to want to know from the from the from the implementation. Thanks so much. Yeah, thanks for a wonderful talk about the golden retriever. We look forward to the collaboration of using LeBron on the digital twin, especially in the arts of surface applications. Yes. Now, we don't have any questions in the chat room yet. If the audience have a question, please raise your hand or feel free to unmute yourself. So, while we're waiting, I may ask some questions. So I'm curious about the potential challenges of AI Applying, say the easy to approach to more complex or real, realistic reservoir models like conversational reservoirs or play or models. So, with the auto encoder be very difficult to train in such large state spaces. Yes, that's actually one of the main issues. I mean, the the, the training process is actually the main issue, right. I mean, it's not necessarily the the training process, but the, the computational time involved in the training process, right. We are testing some of our framework for larger problems using the High Performance Computing here they nm and in takes several hours to do that to the training. Right. So that's something we're looking at a ways to reduce that timing. But we don't I don't have a, I don't have a silver bullet to tell you what to do. I see. So I'll just curious, I do think that you see too, or is it you Oh, framework will work if we simply use linear compression in the state space? Because I mean, it is more easy to. So if you look at, you know, linear compression meaning, like doing an SVD Yes, right. Yes, yes. Yes. Now, right. I mean, the outer encoder is actually a is an SVD. framework, if you will, right. I mean, it's a pod like, right, and we, we use the classical approach, using pod, we've done that, and we showed that we can do that. But again, it has robustness issues, right. And then deciding on a number of reducer states is not necessarily if you follow the recipe like, you know, get the energy function and occurred do a cut off. That doesn't work for for some reason, that doesn't work for much more complicated problem. Right. So I believe they said is, there's a much better way to to do that, that I don't know. We have a question. I can ask questions. You know, the frame of view introduced first to the auto encoder, and then fit the latent space data into, you know, there's a specific form of TMD. In the later part of the talk, right. I was wondering how you parameter rise that framework, maybe I missed that part. Probably explain that. Because you you do have some parameters to tweak, right. I mean, there is a source locations or, you know, whatever the boundary conditions are initial condition, whatever, you're changing that your model has to be robust in parameter change. Right. How do you deal with that? Mistake? The things that I presented here, we have a fixed fixed system. Right. What I haven't shown here is actually the the, the parameterization. Right? We, we don't have a we are working with, you may know Jim Ragusa. Yeah. Right. Yeah. So so we are working with the John reducer to actually do these interpolation, the parameterization interpolation, right. And the decline in the classical way of model reduction for for at least for reservoir simulation. One can parameterize the, the well locations by looking at distances. And we had a paper a couple of years ago on doing that. It works somewhat. Well, right. But it's not, it's not robust again, right. But we are hoping that this collaboration region reducer will lead us to a little bit better, better we have no interpolation. Yeah, he has, he has published some parameters with DMD framework recently. But you may also want to check our recent paper on latent space dynamics identification papers, I can send two of those and both of them talking, talking about the parameterization and also, you know, when you do the parameterizations, you need to sample to two To decide where in the parameter space you need to generate the data. So all those things, those. We'll be glad to take a look at Yes, yeah, yeah, I can forward it to you. Yeah, sure. Okay, yeah. Sounds good. So I don't see any more questions. So if that's the case, let's find started you then again for sharing his excellence research with us. Thanks so much. Thanks for the invitation, and I'll be glad to collaborate more